in a world where technology is advancing
faster than you can see by one question
that keeps buzzing around the tech
Enthusiast Minds is Will AI take over
programming it's the epic battle of BS
and Bots and we are about to embark on a
journey to find out if programmers are
headed towards a robotic takeover so
let's cover each component of a coder's
work and how AI can work alongside these
coders to Aid them in their task the
rise of machines picture this a
futuristic world where AI driven code
Wizards can churn out lines of cod
faster than you can grab a cup of coffee
it's true that Ai and machine learning
have come along way and they are
starting to deel in the world of
programming but let's not forget they
are still learning to tie their virtual
shoe laes AI can assist suggest and even
automate parts of programming process
but it's not quite ready to take over
the Rings The Magic of human creativity
programmers aren't just code monkeys
they are digital Wizards crafting
Solutions with creativity and problem
solving skills that AI can only dream of
think about it AI may know the rules of
Chess but it can't pull out of a Bobby
ficial level mind bend the human touch
and programming is like a Sprinkle of
magic dust it's what makes software more
than just a set of cold functional
instructions collaboration not
domination here's the deal the most
exciting future isn't one where AI take
over but where humans and AI work hand
inand in circuitry AI can handle
repetitive task crunch mindboggling data
and even assist in debugging while
humans focus on Big Picture thinking and
user Centric design it's a tag team for
the ages and together they can take on
coding challenges that were once thought
impossible what about creativity one
thing ail is a creative Sol it can
generate code based on patterns and data
but can it come up with a groundbreaking
app idea a noble game concept or even
even a unique website design not quite
creativity that wonderful spark that
drives Innovation is deeply rooted in
human experience and that's something AI
can't replicate AI as the ultimate
sidekick imagine having an AI sidekick
in your coding Adventures it can spot
errors suggest optimizations and even
provide instant coding references it's
like having Sherlock Holmes as your
coding Bud always ready to assist but
let's remember Holmes needed Watson to
bring out his Brilliance the human
programmers creativity and intuition are
the perfect complement to ai's
analytical Pros ethical consideration as
we venture into this Brave New World
it's crucial to consider the ethical
implications how do we ensure that AI
programming does not lead to bias
discrimination or uned Consequences
human oversight becomes even more
critical in this scenario it's not just
about the code it's about the ethics of
the code the evolution of jobs so let's
address the elephant in the room will
will AI impact jobs in programming World
routine coding task may become automated
but this could create opportunities for
programmers to evolve into their roles
focused on AI supervision ethics and
creativity plus someone has to teach
those AI algorithms right the crystal
ball predicting the future of
programming is like gazing into a
crystal ball with binary code swirling
inside it's safe to say that AI is here
to stay and will continue to evolve but
a complete takeover not so fast the
heart and soul of programming will
always be human and the bond between
programmers and their AI companions will
grow stronger in conclusion the epic
battle of bits and Bots might be a tad
exaggerated while AI is a formidable
force in the programming World it won't
be dethroning human programmers anytime
soon the future isn't about AI taking
over but about humans and AI
collaborating innovating and exploring
New Frontiers together so fellow Tech
adventurers fear note the robots are our
allies in the digital Journey not our
Rivals as you Ponder the future of
programming remember that creativity
ethics and human inity are the secret
source that AI can't replicate and that
my friends is what keeps the programming
World thrilling and utterly
irreplaceably human so happy coding
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a work
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
career success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here